the lefty patrick corbin is on the mound
tonight for the nationals corbin has
been a big concern two starts he has
managed a total of just four and a third
innings of pitching leading things off
it'll be tommy edmund the switch hitter
the breaking ball is sky to the air to
left field fairly deep schwarber moving
back the wind helping it but he has a
play as he backs out of the warning
track makes the catch
for the out here's the pitch swung on
line to left schwarber coming up into a
slide and he makes the catch for the owl
paul goldschmidt
a line drive to left off a 90 mile an
hour fastball and a sliding grab coming
in
by kyle schwarber who's two for two in
left field now nolan arenado with two
out he swings and lines this one towards
schwarber he closes schwaber can't get
it the ball takes a bounce it is backed
up by robles holding aronado to a two
out single
well they didn't try somebody else they
tried scorber again and he almost made a
nice play on that one and arenado has
himself a looping into left center so
here is yada yada molina and molina
hits it out to left again that drops in
for a base hit
everything going to left arenado the
third ball gets away
but gomes is there along with corbin and
because of that throw yadi takes second
so a two-out rally here by saint louis
two singles and now dylan carlson
performing a chance to get out of this
swinging a ground ball to third up with
it is castro crow hop and a throw and
plenty of time to bell
so corbin survives two hits with two out
and two left adam wainwright his third
start tonight went against the nationals
last week and the defense was poor
behind him let him down now it's
stevenson the right fielder there's a
hard hit ground ball to the shortstop
the young has it and throws out andrew
stevenson and now josh harrison on the
ground to de young
two outs here's trey turner with two out
and nobody on swinging a ground ball up
the middle that's a base into the center
field turner takes one back through the
middle
he now has six hits
in his last 13 times up so he's aboard
with two out and josh bell will come up
3-2 pitch to bell he struck him out
comes back to get him two out of runner
a third and adam wainwright will be the
battery's old for three so far this year
and the o2 swing at a miss gomes has to
throw down to bell as wait wright took
off completes the strikeout two to three
second strikeout for corbin corbin will
bat with two on corbin is two for three
a pair of singles so far this year
there's a chopper to the second baseman
edmund throws out corbin and the
national strand two the second time
around for the cardinals against patrick
corbin in the third swing in a pop-up up
the first base line bell chasing into
foul ground goes into a slide makes the
catch and holds on good play by josh
bell a little blue pop-up not in the air
all that high and bell goes sliding
along the grass and out of the warning
track to make the catch an outstanding
play now the nationals have something
brewing the table set for the heart of
the order turner batting in the third
spot here's a 1-0
ground ball
the turn
and double play they do get the speedy
turner on the ground ball 6-4-3
grazed by the cutter and so bell goes
down to first and that'll leave it up to
schwarber the 2-2
tails back in and it's a strikeout of
schwarber and the nationals unable to
score despite first and second nobody
out third time through the lineup let's
see how bueno navigates this the o2
pitch from wainwright
curveball swung on foul tip into the
catcher's mitt strike three wainwright
has his fourth strikeout two fast outs
in the fifth inning a swing and a miss
harrison strikes out and that's two in
the inning five in the game for wayno it
seems like both pitchers are kind of
feeding off each other right through
five innings corbin 62 pitches
wainwright 68. and tommy edmond rips it
oh what a stop here by starlin castro
and he beat it out
so lead off man aboard for the first
time tonight for the cardinals and
breaks the streak of 11 straight retired
for corbin here's goldschmidt swinging a
crown ball to third can they turn it
castro to second for one harrison the
first two
a double play
and the lead off single is erased
so arenado bats with nobody on there's
another 3-2 to arenado swinging a high
pop-up shallow center harrison going out
the second baseman robles and stevenson
coming in robles will call off harrison
went out there pretty good ways and it's
robles to haul it in this feels like an
important inning for adam wainwright as
he's working in the sixth inning and
facing the middle of the order turner
bell and schwarber in a nothing nothing
game
these are the guys you got to get past
it's his spot struck him out turner is
arguing again
three strikeouts in a row six tonight
for wayne oh here's josh bell between a
high drive to right williams going back
to the warning track near the wall he
leaps and it's gone
josh bell's first home run as a national
breaks the scoreless duel here in the
sixth inning nationals won
cardinals nothing
and it was adam wainwright who blinked
first in this game
fastball and he struck him out seven
tonight for adam wainwright well you
gotta wonder why corbin is out of this
game i i just i know he struggled and
maybe you're trying to give him an
outing in which okay he leaves with a
one-run lead but you turn it over to
your bullpen and essentially after the
first inning no high-stress situation
for him yada yada with a ten pitch at
bat draws the lead off walk and the
cardinals very quickly have the tying
run aboard
and it is dylan carlson batting from the
left side now carlson rips it into
center it's well hit robles back at the
wall it's over his head and off the wall
yachty
come on yachty dylan carlson
winds up at third
a triple that ties the game up at one
damage done two pitches after the
lead-off walk cardinals are on the board
there's your fly ball you got to do
right there out to left schwarber with
the catch carlson tagging up from third
and he will score and the cardinals have
a 2-1 lead on the rbi by austin dean
adam wainwright will get to continue his
outing into the bottom of the seventh
inning so wainwright will face the lower
third of the order and it's a called
strike three on the outside corner he
dotted the outside corner gomes doesn't
like it but a perfect pitch from adam
wainwright a swing and a miss he struck
him out back-to-back strikeouts in the
seventh inning and wainwright
has struck out six
of the last eight batters curveball
swinging a miss he strikes out the side
adam wainwright is getting stronger in
this game gallegos has been shaky to
start this inning walking to hit batters
would qualify in the shanky category
wouldn't it we are at the tough part of
the nationals lineup again and now it's
turner swinging a ground ball base head
down the right field line stevenson
around third he's coming home he has
tied the game
what we got we are going five minutes in
the eighth in the eighth inning i've
never seen this in my life this is
highly unorthodox to go five infielders
two outfielders in the eighth inning
isn't this something rolling the dice
mike shield
castro is all for one against gallegos
fastball outside corner and struck him
out
and the cardinals will go to a
traditional defense all the shenanigans
with the positioning the ball wasn't put
in play the game tied it's up to yon
gomes
and the nats take the lead on a bases
loaded walk after all of this stuff
happening in the eighth inning right
hand is trying to
try and close it out and so now the
cardinals are down to their last out of
the game lolita off second two out top
of the ninth pitch swinging a fly ball
left field toward the line schwarber
coming in he's there he makes the cash
and bang zuma curly w's in the box